good afternoon ladies and gentlemen uh
thanks for joining us and welcome to
this program i'm bob turner i'm the
associate director of the center for
national security law at the university
of virginia law school
we've gathered here to learn about a
very important new book by a very
prominent and impressive young scholar
the topic of course is the vietnam war
both i and our my our center's
co-founder professor john norton moore
i've been working on the vietnam issue
for more than 40 years indeed we became
friends in
1974 because of our interest in vietnam
and uh i think we probably teach the
only law school class in the country
about the vietnam war that might not
have been true 30 years ago but we find
it's a wonderful opportunity to look at
issues that are very relevant today and
were relevant even before the current
armed conflicts in afghanistan and
iraq
we look at things like the law governing
the initiation of coercion the
relationship between congress and the
president under the constitution on war
powers
the law governing the treatment of
detainees and prisoners of war
a wide range of issues that are that go
far beyond vietnam
come up during the course and we we
started it out thinking it would be
we'd be changing the subject every
second or third year
but the student reaction to the seminar
was so popular that we've kept it now
for it's been over 15 years
uh we first met mark moyer in april of
2000 when we invited him to take part in
a conference at our law school
commemorating the 2000 of the 25th
anniversary of the 19th the april 30th
1975 fall of saigon
mark presented a truly outstanding paper
which appears in our book the real
lessons of the vietnam war which is
edited by john moore and myself
mark has continued his superb work he uh
his latest volume is a landmark
contribution it's the first of a
two-part
uh uh of two two volumes on this topic
we're very honored to play host to this
program and which is being covered of
course by c-span
and we hope this will further public
interest in both the book and the issue
it addresses
the vietnam war obviously is of more
than historical interest as many of the
lessons being drawn from that conflict
today for places like iran and iraq and
afghanistan and perhaps iran you never
can tell
are being drawn from vietnam and in many
cases i would submit are based upon
misinformation and misunderstanding
about what really happened in vietnam
i i've been amused over the years at
listening to experts talk about the
lessons that we should draw from vietnam
and
one of them always is you never go to
war without public support and you never
go to war without the approval in
support of congress of course
in the months surrounding the gulf of
tonkin incident and the enactment of
statutory authorization for war
lbj's public approval rating shot up 58
percent
a full 30 point increase
congress in passing a statute that
jay william fulbright said was
authorizing the president to go to war
did so by a 99.6 percent vote
unanimous in the house and 88 to 2 in
the senate uh i would submit that
neither one of those particular lessons
is is very valid
uh there are lots of lessons about the
vietnam war being an unwinnable war we
should have understood that
i'm not alone in believing that the
vietnam war was not only eminently
winnable but that in fact we had it won
before congress threw in the towel i
worked in the senate during the last
five years of the war or last few years
of the war sorry i worked there five
years but not the war ended during that
time and i think i learned more about
why we lost the vietnam war as a senate
staff member than i did in my two tours
in vietnam
george santana warned us that those who
fail to learn from history are doomed to
repeat it i think we need to take some
take that seriously and i think we can
turn to mark to help us understand what
really happened because if you learned
the wrong lessons from history
you're not going to do well
mark moore air holds a ba summa [ __ ]
laude from harvard where he graduated
first in the history department and his
thesis was selected the most outstanding
thesis in the department
he holds a phd from cambridge university
he's taught at cambridge at ohio state
university at texas a m and at present
he is associate professor
at the marine corps university in
quantico virginia not far from where we
are today
cambridge university press has in its
wisdom recently nominated his newest
book
triumph forsaken the vietnam war
1954-1965
for the pulitzer prize in history
the for the for the past month since it
came out it has been the number one book
on amazon.com's vietnam war bestseller
list
his previous book phoenix and the birds
of prey the cia's secret campaign to
destroy the viet cong was a landmark
contribution to the scholarship
the new volume takes it even one step
further and is as important as any
single book i know of in the vietnam war
and i can only tell you that i'm waiting
for the the second volume in this set or
the third volume from professor from dr
moyer
to come out so i can continue to learn
from that without further ado please
give a warm welcome to dr mark moyer
[Applause]
thanks very much for that introduction
bob
i'd like to thank several people
in addition to bob the center for for
national security law for sponsoring
this event
i'd like to thank my wife kelly who's
here my parents burt and marjorie moyer
who are also here
and my brother david and his wife monica
for coming
merle pribino who i'm going to talk some
more about
came i'd like to thank him i've had some
folks come in from out of town
jay weith from delaware and then it had
a bit of a drive to get here
and also the
vietnam veterans who are here both
vietnamese and american
and some other vietnamese friends of
ours
and in addition i'd like to thank
the former students and current students
of mine who turned up for this there's
some from every year that i've taught
at the marine corps university and
some of my colleagues from the
university
uh
like to of course also thank c-span for
coming here and the staff of the hilton
garden in fairfax for
arranging all the details of this
before i talk i need to explain that
these are my opinions not those of the
marine corps the federal government
of which i am employ
i'm going to talk
first a little bit about
how
the project got started
i started working on was now triumph
forsaken
in 1999
and
from doing my first book on the phoenix
program i knew
that there were some
holes in the
existing historiography on the latter
part of the war which is 67 onwards
and
i expected to rely on what i'd
identified there and when i was writing
about the early part which is covered in
trent forsaken
i had in that book relied on the many
many books that have been written
assuming that
on the assumption that
the
sheer volume of this
meant that there had been some sort of
consensus that had been reached
as i started working on the early part
of the war
i started to have my suspicions that the
consensus view that had been built up
over this time
itself was
full of serious holes and so what i
decided to do was to go back to the
primary documents themselves
rather than just relying on
amalgamating
the works of others who had already
worked on this
and as i got into it the more i got into
it i found that in fact there's a
tremendous amount of information out
there that just hadn't been used or had
been
distorted
and at about the same time i realized
that i had the good fortune of
coming into contact with mr merle
priveno here
who introduced me to a treasure trove of
vietnamese communist documents which
allowed me and and other scholars to
understand the war from the enemy side
to a degree we could not before and to
understand
their intentions and capabilities and
that understanding has really changed
how i have looked at the war and how i
portray it
through this process of course it took
longer to get through
all the material that i planned and
that's part of why i divided in half but
over the course of working on the book i
decided that really the entire
conventional view of vietnam during the
54 to 65 period had been
grossly misrepresented
now vietnam of course is a big subject
today because of what's going on in iraq
and i should start off by saying that
the iraq was not on my mind as i was
working on this i started on it well
before it began
and the purpose of the book is to
understand the past and not try to serve
as a tool for the present
and the word iraq is not mentioned in
the book i don't talk about current
events but there are some
things we can learn from it i'll touch
on those a little bit
briefly because i think it's
useful for the when we're comparing iraq
to vietnam that the people who actually
know vietnam well
are the ones doing it
and one of the big things we are hearing
a lot about today is the strategic
importance of
iraq and the
necessity of the united states going in
there was it a strategic mistake
and of course now there's debates about
the next strategic option and
we're hearing a lot there's a tremendous
amount written there's seems to be a new
book just about every day on iraq coming
out
the
there are significant perils with
vietnam in this respect
the the truth is that
the key facts on something like this are
not really going to emerge and the whole
picture won't become clear for i think
a number of decades now we're now 41
years after
the 1965 decision to go into vietnam
and i found evidence that i think
fundamentally changes how we look at
that and if you go back
and look at what
journalists or other commentators were
writing in 1965
about vietnam clearly they were missing
a tremendous amount
of information there was more available
to the president certainly
and despite our belief that the press
gets a hold of everything there's
certainly things that i'm sure are known
to
the administration that aren't known to
the general
public
i'll first talk about the strategic
importance of vietnam why i think it was
in fact strategically important in the
standard view that you'll hear is that
vietnam was not important because ho chi
minh at heart was really a nationalist
more than a communist
and that vietnam and china had this
historic enmity and therefore
vietnam and china were bound to fall out
and we could have used ho chi minh as an
ally
and i take issue with that on a number
of fronts first is that i argue that ho
chi minh was not in fact a nationalist
and there's a lot of different
things that
point this direction we know he
repeatedly praises the internationalism
of of
lenin and others
and he frequently throughout his career
speaks of
promoting international revolution and
when he's trying to
encourage
his
partisans to move forward on a
particular activity he frequently
emphasizes that we're part of this
global revolution
it's not simply a narrow nationalist
enterprise
he's on record for denouncing tito and
others who put what he calls bourgeois
nationalism in front of
the communist internet internationalism
he commends the suppression of the
nationalist communists in hungary in
1956 which occurred almost exactly 50
years ago from this date
he kills tens of thousands of people in
the process of
undertaking communist policies first in
1945 and 6
when he gets temporary control over
parts of vietnam and then
in the mid 50s when he regains control
and institutes a series of land uh
what he calls land reform
and clearly kills a lot more people
incidentally than the south vietnamese
kill
and if you look simply at how he sets up
his government as well it's clearly
along doctrinaire marxist leninist lines
also when you look at the relationship
between vietnam and china you'll find
out that in fact it's not at all one of
hostility
vietnam
becomes essentially an independent
vassal state of china in the late 10th
century and from then on
very rarely is there actually com combat
between china and vietnam and in fact
the
instances where they where there are
there is some sort of fighting it's
usually because the vietnamese are
involved in some kind of civil war and
one of the factions invites the chinese
on the other side
there's a long history of cooperation in
the late 19th century when france comes
in
and attempts to colonize vietnam
china is actually called upon by the
vietnamese to come protect them because
vietnam is a vassal china is the
protector
and that's their role that they do
attempt that they lose to the france to
france and they're no longer a vassal
state
if you look at ho chi minh himself he
was actually very pro-chinese in his
outlook and he spent a good part of his
career with the chinese he's actually a
member of the chinese army in world war
ii
and if you go forward to the 54 to 65
period he's clearly
working closely with the chinese he gets
a lot of chinese assistance in defeating
the
french
and in his land reform campaign and
other programs he defers in many cases
to his chinese adviser
the true nature of of conflict in
vietnam i argue is not one of
fighting
external enemies but rather one of
vietnamese fighting amongst themselves
and sometimes with american support and
this is
in my opinion what the vietnam war
essentially is it's a war among
vietnamese with both sides receiving
extensive power
support from great powers
now the the main rationale for u.s
intervention i argue is that
they were concerned about the so-called
domino theory whereby
the fall of vietnam would lead to other
states falling to communism
and there are a lot of other people who
have said that although others would
disagree but
what i also say which hasn't generally
been said is that in fact this theory
was valid
now the
criticism of the domino theory
predominantly is that
vietnam falls in
1975 the dominoes don't fall so
therefore
there was never a threat but i argue
that
the situation changes enormously between
65 and 75
and you can't simply look at 75 the area
is not frozen in time there's a
tremendous amount of
activities going on that will change the
dynamics of power in the region for
example the sino-soviet split
it widens and and north vietnam's
relations become significantly closer
with the soviets
during that period and china china goes
through the cultural revolution which
fundamentally changes its foreign policy
so we really need to look at what's
going on in 1965 rather than 1975.
it's clear from the record that in 1965
hanoi and beijing are working closely
not just on vietnam but in fact
on revolution throughout southeast asia
they're talking about
expanding
their military activities eventually to
thailand
and
thailand probably a springboard for
moving into other areas
in terms of the
non-communist countries in the region
this is a particularly interesting
subject because
while there's been tremendous amount of
talk about the domino theory and
and why it wasn't true there's been
actually very little research on
what was going on in those other asian
countries at that time the general view
is that there was not support in these
countries
for the vietnam war but
going back looking through the records
diplomatic records
i found in fact that most of the
countries in asia in fact adhere to the
domino theory
and except for this few that were
sympathetic to china most of them
actually favored u.s intervention
in vietnam and they argued that if we're
not for u.s invention
their future uh was going to look very
dark
they
also a lot of them offer resources
troops or
economic assistance
and some of them will not end up
providing that although in truth the
reason for that is that
they
either don't have the proper resources
or
or the united states or vietnam for one
reason another says well we don't thanks
but we really don't need it
i spent a good amount of time looking at
indonesia
which is the most important country in
southeast asia because of its
population its natural resources and its
strategic location along the world sea
routes
and at this time
indonesia is very clearly moving to the
left towards alliance with north vietnam
and china
which is very contrary to u.s interests
and if you look back in fact the us's
frequently talks about how indonesia is
the real prize in southeast asia not
vietnam is simply
a way of preventing the enemy from
getting to indonesia and some other
places
i found particularly noteworthy in
february of 65
there is an indonesian general who goes
to the americans and says
you need to get tough in vietnam
general uh
president johnson needs to
start acting like he's a powerful person
use his power and that
the fate of all of asia will be
contingent on how
the united states behaves in vietnam
and i've also found evidence that
american subsequent american
intervention actually
contributes to the indonesian generals
later that year
withstanding the sicarno and his
communist allies
and
turning that country into an ally of the
united states which is absolutely
critical i think in the history of the
cold war
the most important country and age of
all japan and i found in in mid-1965
edwin rush reishauer who's the
ambassador there and is hardly a staunch
cold warrior
is saying that the u.s is to suffer
defeat in vietnam that japan is going to
move towards a position
uh of accommodation with china and it's
going to
abandon its security arrangements with
the united states uh which he of course
viewed as being tremendously damaging
for the united states
now one
figure i talk about in great length in
the book is south vietnam's president no
din ziem who rules from
july of 1954 until november of 1963
and
i believe he has been
mistreated by history
he's an authoritarian figure and that
has led to a lot of criticism of him in
the west
but i argue that given the
fractious nature of the society the
subversion that's going on that
that in fact you need a leader of that
type and that's something that i'll come
to you later again because it's
certainly an issue relevant today and he
is in fact
much more humane than his communist
counterparts in north vietnam
the uh
and there's a constant theme throughout
vietnam where you have two rival groups
of americans one of whom is saying
that
vietnam really should be
just like the united states and
political solutions that work in the
united states
probably work over there the other group
is saying that vietnam is culturally
fundamentally different and that you
can't apply the same solutions
there that you would here and so the
those who argue that they're more or
less the same or anti-gm those who view
vietnam on its own terms tend to be in
favor of siem
ziem is very effective
in his early years in stomping out
communist subversion we know by late 50s
that communists are in great disarray
in south vietnam
and not in 1959 the communists will
decide that they're going to move to a
period of armed insurrection
because they are in such dire straits uh
now we get to 1960 the insurgency begins
the
communists are actually pretty
successful which i attribute to
the charismatic attraction of their
leaders they the fact that they do have
this armed force
and also to their to a lesser extent
their land reform programs and siem had
undertaken
land reform
in the late 50s but he had set the
maximum holding pretty high at
100 hectares or 247 acres and so there's
still a lot of people who don't have
land and are
ready to listen to the to the viet cong
who are promising them ownership of this
land
although they secretly in the end plan
to collectivize it
uh
now part of the criticism that's made
for the of the government for its
problems in 1960 and 61 is that
the government was too conventional in
its approach
that the americans helped them develop a
conventional army that really wasn't
appropriate to the security needs
i take issue with that i think for one
thing they did certainly need a
conventional capability because there is
this threat from the north and as we'll
see ultimately it is that conventional
threat that will cause them the greatest
harm
and they do have some counter guerrilla
forces militia-type forces with the
self-defense corps the civil guard
but those suffer from poor leadership uh
partly to do with the fact that a lot of
the leaders are holdovers from the
colonial era who aren't particularly
good leaders
and they also get little funding and
equipment and this is primarily
due to the american ambassador elbridge
dubrow who
argues that there's really not that big
of a communist threat
in 59 early 60 and that really the these
units should be trained as a civilian
police force just like the michigan
state police and they don't need
significant weapons so they end up
having either very old rifles or pistols
and they're facing viet cong who have
sub-machine guns and other more powerful
weapons
the nazim will turn things around in
1962 and 1963
and this is primarily because of
leadership and i think in vietnam almost
everything is contingent upon
leadership
he sends out a new generation that he
has trained
starting in the mid 50s and this
generation starts coming of age in late
61 starts getting into the most
important positions and he sets up the
strategic hamlet program which is
staffed with the republican youth which
has a lot of the up-and-comers in it
there is also
more u.s assistance coming in although
that's i think secondary importance but
this is now documented wealth not from
just us sources but also from the
vietnamese communist sources and even
the u.s press who would later
dispute this on this
classic case of we're looking at it from
the other side has really fundamentally
changed how we view the history
the big event that will lead to dm's
undoing is the buddhist crisis of 1963
these there's a group that's called the
militant buddhists that come out and
accuse him of religious persecution
religious discrimination
and
i think that most of their allegations
in fact prove to be fraudulent
we now know
that there was communist involvement in
these movements and they were in fact
aimed at subverting the government
and at the time this was not understood
by
u.s intelligence
simply didn't have the sources the red
sources to figure this out zm had long
been maintained maintaining this and
turns out he was right
the u.s very much puts pressure on ziem
to compromise to make concessions and
this is again a case where trying to
apply american remedies to vietnamese
problems
what happens when you give when he makes
these concessions is that
in fact it does not appease the
buddhists and they simply view it as a
sign of weakness and they start
demanding more
and for the vietnamese government
it comes across as a loss of prestige a
loss of face and for the vietnamese
government as for many other east asian
governments
tolerating open defiance is is a sign of
weakness
this will come to a head in the middle
of august when there's massive
demonstrations in saigon organized by
these militant buddhists and at this
time
it's uh
the changeover between american
ambassadors
the outgoing ambassadors frederick
nolting
and
actually mrs nolting was hoping to be
here today but but she was uh taken ill
um
but uh he was much more pro-ziem than
his successor henry cavett lodge he will
come in
now at this time
generals are arguing that the government
cannot afford to tolerate these sorts of
protests it's losing it's uh
it's losing face it's losing prestige
we've got to crack down and so
ziem says okay you're right
we will go ahead and we'll use the army
to clear out clear up these protests he
adds don't use force against them
so they go ahead and do that
and political situation seems to have
been
solved the opposition dies down the
government's prestige increases but
the u.s government and press see this as
an act of repression that
again violates our code of conduct
so
there is an effort first by the press to
discredit ziamen to put the blame on him
in fact the generals who approve this
ultimately will start to back away once
they see the us is so
hostile to this reaction
the
new ambassador lodge along with his
state department allies decide that they
should in fact now
attempt to get the generals to launch a
coup not realizing in fact the generals
were behind this whole thing
uh and so
the plotting begins in late august
uh
and this time
the u.s press becomes increasing
increasingly prominent
most particularly david halberstam and
neil sheehan
who are young reporters in their 20s in
vietnam
and they have for a while held a grudge
against the government because
the government both the zm government
the american government are trying to
limit the flow of information
and again for
south vietnamese government in
particular
it's a loss of face to admit military
defeats military problems so
uh zm government wants to
to keep the press away from those facts
and and these
journalists think they have a right to
knowing everything that's going on
and they also think they're smarter than
the us officials who are out there
uh the press is also relying on some
pretty dubious sources at this time um
most notably fems won on and uh from tao
who are two communist agents
working within the south vietnamese
government
and uh turns out hammerstein later will
admit that that on is actually his chief
source on the attitudes of the south
vietnamese officer corps
which is critical because halbersham is
making these reports of
terrible dissatisfaction among the
officer corps museum
they're also
feeding information to ambassador lodge
ambassador lodge
becomes buddies with these guys and
they're trading information back and
forth
uh and lodge actually is paying more
attention to him than to the cia and the
military
now when the the coup ultimately will
will
not turn out his plan the journalists
who have been pushing this line that
if we only got a new leader we'd fix all
these problems
they
start start telling a somewhat different
story which is that
really the war has been was going
terribly
up until in by late 63
and
so these problems we have afterwards
aren't really a change because it was
already lost by that point and
clearly that's not the case but through
their influence
with
especially with the us government both
in washington and saigon
i think it's not an exaggeration to say
that halbersham and sheehan
did
more damage to the interests of this
country than any other reporters in our
history
now president kennedy at this time is
watching the coup and seeing what's
going on he's pretty hesitant to
authorize the coup that ambassador lodge
is stirring up
most of his advisors think it's not a
good idea his close advisors
there's a lot of new information that's
come out on this it's now clear that
lodge was acting behind the president's
back without
telling him and that kennedy a few days
before the coup finally figures out
that lodge has been in contact with
these plotters
against presidential orders
and he tries to rein him in he
sends a message out saying
uh ambassador lodge you need to go to
these individuals and tell them we don't
think a coup is a good idea right now
and lodge kind of stalls and then
finally says um i can't really do that
and doesn't actually pass the message
and and kennedy would have i think fired
him had he been anyone else but henry
cabot lodge but lodge is actually a
leading contender for the
presidential nomination of the
republican party
in
1964 and kennedy's afraid that that if
he fires him this is going to be used
against him
in the campaign
kennedy ironically had sent lodge out
there because he thought it was would
promote bipartisanship
and it would
uh prevent him from taking all the heat
for vietnam but it turns out to backfire
on him as far as the issue of of jfk
wanting to withdraw
there's been a lot of good stuff written
on this already
and i agree with those who think that
kennedy did not have plans to withdraw
at that time
uh it's not clear
he doesn't make clear what he would have
done had it come to
the dire situation of 1965 you basically
appeared to be of the view that he kind
of figured that out when he got there
but
based on what is going on in 65 i think
it's safe to say that he would have done
the same thing as as lyndon johnson
ultimately does
so the coup
takes place november 1 1963.
the
south vietnamese generals
overcome ziem and his loyal forces
on some of cm's loyal forces have been
put under
the military leadership at the
insistence of the americans
sam is apprehended november 2nd
he appealed to henry cavanaugh lodge had
originally promised him safe passage but
lodge backs off uh he's sam's captured
and the generals kill him although this
becomes a big cause of unrest because a
lot of the the generals had not wanted
that and they had a lot of respect for
zm
now
i mentioned earlier there's this
view that was portrayed that the war was
already going very badly by the time the
coup comes
but
there's a tremendous amount of
information which i include in the book
that shows in fact the war is going very
well
as of the end of october 1963 and that
it plunges dramatically after that point
in time
there
are numerous arrests of leaders of this
young government including a lot of the
effective people that he had cultivated
he most of the provincial chiefs who are
running pacification are replaced
the leadership of the strategic hamlet
program the republican youth are kicked
out the militia
and the strategic handle militia in a
lot of places are actually disarmed
because the new regime is not sure how
loyal they are
the new leaders themselves fight amongst
each other
and they fail to provide leadership to
those below them there's a
series of coups that occur
as a result of the u.s taking a stand
against siem on the issue of
political crackdowns the new government
is more tolerant of of
opposition and there continues to be
opposition from these buddhists
despite the fact that they're getting
all their desires satisfied essentially
um but this again the government
under these conditions is made to appear
weak uh they're intimidated into doing
whatever these buddhists want and it
leads to political
chaos
now
1964 as as the political situation is
falling apart in south vietnam
president johnson's got his eye on the
1964 election
and
he's running against barry goldwater who
is talking about getting tough in
vietnam
and johnson decides he's going to
portray himself as the peace candidate
although his advisers are telling him
privately that he should tone it down
because
he may actually go to war in vietnam in
a few months
but
and at the same time he's also looking
uh he's influenced heavily by academic
theorists who are who have these new
ideas about how you manage conflict
and uh there's a provocation talking
golf
early august of 64.
and according to these theories
the appropriate response is to take some
sort of limited action that will signal
your resolve to the enemy and johnson
does do that
i mean he's
accused of wanting to stir things up but
he's trying to keep vietnam on the back
burner
but
this actually has the opposite effect on
the north vietnamese because the limited
nature of it leads them to conclude
that the us really is pretty weak and
lacks resolve and johnson can't fight
and so this along with the problems in
the south
will lead to a north vietnamese
conventional invasion in late 1964.
and this again gets to the discussion of
was the south vietnamese army properly
suited for its tasks
clearly by 64 this conventional force
that the u.s has helped promote is
very useful
the communists describe it as being the
main impediment to victory
and
there's a lot of battles that haven't
been covered before that i look at where
the communists are employing in excess
of a thousand
troops and you simply cannot
defeat that kind of enemy with small
militia or police forces
now johnson eventually this this
offensive by the communists will force
johnson in june of 65
to uh to intervene and to commit the u.s
to the ground war
i argue that johnson misses some very
important strategic opportunities during
this period 64 and 65
and he's largely ignoring the advice of
his military advisors
and
preferring that of his civilian advisers
which is certainly something that has
happened since that time
the with respect to the invasion of
north vietnam he's afraid
some of his military advisors think we
should invade north vietnam a source of
enemy power
and johnson's afraid that china is going
to come back in like they did in korea
but we now know from the chinese side
that they
are as much afraid of another korean war
as the united states is
and at least up until march 65 they
almost certainly would not have
intervened
the other option is
sending u.s troops into laos the site of
the ho chi minh trail
which the communists are using as their
main supply line into south vietnam
now the
johnson civilians at this time are
arguing that the ho chi minh trail is
really not that important the insurgency
is largely largely self-sustaining
that uh and people will concede maybe
later on it was important but even 64 i
argue that it is essential to what
they're trying to do
first of all
they uh
talk about in their recollections the
communist memoirs about how this was
critical to to their effort and if you
look at what's going on in the war
they're using a lot of heavy weaponry
that can only come from one place
which is north vietnam via the ho chi
minh trail
i also argue that that cutting the ho
chi minh trail is in fact feasible which
a lot of people have argued with one one
of the interesting things i learned from
the north vietnamese documents is there
was actually a ho chi minh trail within
vietnam
in 1960
and that in fact this young government
succeeds in cutting that trail
with about a division worth of troops
the trail subsequently moved to the
western side of the anime mountains into
laos and a lot of debate whether the u.s
should go in there we don't
but
the
territory in laos is not very conducive
to
sending lots of supplies there's only a
few places where
where vehicular traffic can easily go
across and so it appears uh
just that from that and based on the 60
experience it shouldn't be that hard
and in fact we now have both communist
vietnamese sources and even soviet
sources that say that about three to
five u.s divisions would have been
enough to
to stop that traffic which a lot less
than what we ultimately
deployed vietnam
another point i'd like i'd like to
emphasize in the book is that
there is a lot of heroism both by the
americans and the vietnamese at this
time
neil sheehan at one point calls the
vietnam war the war without heroes and
uh
and i i agree that the only reason it
may be perceived like that is that the
that's how the media has sought to
portray it i mean clearly vietnam you
don't have someone like uh joshua
chamberlain or sergeant york or audi
murphy but if you look at what's
actually going on there are there is a
great deal of uh heroic action both by
individuals and by
by units and most of this hasn't been
documented so i go into it in the book
in significant detail i'll just mention
a couple examples
november 25th
1962 south vietnamese army
force of about a hundred at the outpost
of fort cha
is attacked by uh up to a thousand enemy
soldiers
north korea soldiers
the government forces have prepared
their defenses very well and they've got
some howitzers in the area that they're
that they've lined up anticipating the
successful or the enemy attack
and uh the defense proves to be
extremely defective excuse me effective
the vietcong leave 124 dead on the
battlefield certainly they took some
more people with them
government's total casualties are 10
wounded no dead
something we don't hear about another
example may 11th 1965 at song bay
just a handful of us advisors in
advisory compound
uh under attack by two vietcong
battalions that are in possession of
eight heavy weapons companies they
managed to hold them off until they
exhaust most of their heavy ammunition
which again heavy weaponry very
important by this time
and by the next morning the south
vietnamese regiment comes in and
dislodges the vietcong from song bay
individual
who really distinguishes himself one of
many during this period is marvin
shields
he's present at the attack on dungswa on
june 10th of 65
when two vietcong regiments attack the
town
they overrun a lot of position
government positions
but the government headquarters and the
advisory compound or excuse me special
forces advisory compound are still
intact
and shields is seen and there's lots of
documentation of this jumping from
position to position
to distribute ammunition to
help the wounded and to fire at the
enemy
and he shot twice during that period
including one that takes out a good part
of his face
but at one point there's an enemy
machine gun that's put up that is a
grave threat to their position
and he's volunteers are asked to to go
with a rocket launcher to
to put that out and he volunteers
although he's never
used one of these weapons before and he
goes
uh with charles williams who was also
decorated for this
um they go run through exposing
themselves to fire carry out the mission
he's hit on the way back
shields is and he'll die later that day
and he receives a medal of honor for
this
the u.s navy names a frigate after him
but he's still not really someone we
know
uh again this problem unfortunately we
see a lot of today there's a lot of
heroism on the part of us in iraq now if
you go on the internet look up navy
crossed or distinguished service cross
for example you'll see plenty of
examples
but we don't see
that in our press which uh
and i think certainly is an audience for
it but um i think it has to do with the
attitudes of our of our press in this
country unfortunately
uh in conclusion i'll just
reiterate that vietnam was not in fact
an act of
either hubris or strategic buffoonery
that
in fact it was based on relatively sound
understanding of the
international situation
and this of course again is
very relevant to our times because
vietnam remains
a central issue in our history that that
people base current decisions on
so it's not something we should be
hanging our heads about uh with the
exception of uh the few people who are
involved in cm's overthrow like albert
sam and sheehan
and uh
state department people who are involved
although most of them are now
deceased and as i mentioned to the to a
lesser extent the decision not to go
into north vietnam or laos in 65 is also
another big mistake we make
but
certainly the american deaths in that
conflict were not in vain or in service
of some
lost cause because we do
ultimately achieve our aims of saving
southeast asia from communism
had the united states not gone into
vietnam in 1965. it's almost certain
that the other dominoes of the area
would fall in indonesia
thailand malaysia
for example countries that are of great
importance to us today and that
certainly would have had major
ramifications for the cold war and in
fact would have a lot of ramifications
for our current competition with china
today
veterans day as you know is uh is
approaching
and i think in that spirit we should
thank the
american and south vietnamese veterans
both those who are
still walking amongst us and those who
are not
for protecting the united states and
asia
at this time and performing
great deeds that will continue to adorn
the tapestry of the vietnam war both for
the united states and vietnam
thank you very much
[Applause]
as someone who has taught seminars on
vietnam for undergraduates graduates
military officers over a number of years
i can only say i hope this book is
widely adopted and is read by the next
generation of americans because an awful
lot of our current leaders
our current opinion molders
misunderstand what happened and mark has
presented just a superb summary that
that really
fits with my own experience in vietnam
and studying vietnam here he mentioned
note in zm and i recently had an
encounter with someone who was talking
about i know what it was it was vietnam
magazine had a column referring to
washington's monster note nzm or
something like that and it really i was
not you know i was talking to uh bob
sorley the author of a better war last
he was lecturing in my seminar on
wednesday and
he shared my outrage over that
i had a conversation in 19 december
nineteen sixty eight with dr tron von
doe who had been the state of vietnam's
uh senior representative at the geneva
conference in
june july may june july of 1954 and he
had later uh broken with note in cm but
he said this was a very great patriot a
very able man and a and a
fine leader
more interestingly in 1971 i was driving
back from
quinoa what
from ben tray from what we call quinoa
province and what the viet cong call ben
tray province where they claim the the
revolution began
in 1960
ignoring the fact that hanoi has now
admitted that may 19 1959
the party in hanoi made a decision to
open the ho chi minh trail and liberate
south vietnam this whole issue of the
nlf being autonomous and so forth
doesn't survive the admissions that have
come out of hanoi but
driving back to saigon
late one evening in 1971 i was
accompanied by a man named
who was i think probably the most senior
or most important defector at least that
i encountered in my five
trips to vietnam between 1968 and the
final evacuation in 1975.
he had been chief of culture education
propaganda and training for ben trey
province and was a very senior player
and i asked him just to pass the time
what did you think of zm
and he said when we heard zm had been
killed we thought it must be a trick
because we could not believe the
americans would be so stupid as to allow
anything to happen to zm
he said as a senior party leader
i like other senior party leaders viewed
siam as a great patriot in the same
category as ho chi minh but because he
would not accept the party's leadership
we had to discredit him and so he
denounced him as an american puppet as a
as corrupt as a tyrant as this or that
but it was very clear he had the highest
respect for his um and
that was the experience i also found
that in doing my i did my honors thesis
on the war back in 66
uh and in uh reading the french
histories of vietnam consistently the
french scholars uh it's not consistently
but most of the best french scholars had
praised for zm even though he had
repeatedly refused to serve in there as
a puppet in their governments he had
been asked to head their government time
and again
he would not be their puppet he would
not be japan's puppet when the japanese
took over during world war ii and it
turned out he would not be an american
puppet either when you go through the
pentagon papers one of the interesting
things or the frustration of the
american diplomats who can't understand
why unlike so many third world leaders
this guy was not going to be an american
puppet he was not going to be the
just take orders from the pro council
of the united states in in saigon and
he uh
in fact i remember one of the big fights
that comes out of the pentagon papers
was the imwa said i'm going to face a
guerrilla war i need to have a military
design to fight guerrilla wars
and the americans said no no you're
going to face a korean war 38th parallel
invasion across the 17th parallel you
need a large american style army and zm
said no i don't and they said if you
want money for it that's the army we're
going to buy you and then
of course we stuck them with that army
and then when congress cut off
all the ammunition and funds and pol and
supplies it didn't function very well in
the final months anyway
i've said way too much i'm going to turn
over the
microphone back to mark for questions
and i always like to see if anybody's
really angry give them the first shot i
shouldn't do that to mark but if anybody
really wants to get in a different
viewpoint
raise your hand or something like that
that sounds good i'll leave it here but
donna can you catch it better not do
that she probably would can
raise your hand and god will bring you
over here on this side
or right here
mark i found your comments on president
diem fascinating and i look forward to
reading uh that part of the book
my take on them has always been
not that
he was insufficiently democratic or
not that he was
too autocratic
but
primarily that he was inflexible
that he refused to modernize
that he was fairly incompetent as a
ruler and he just didn't know how to
govern now i assume you're going to
knock all those arguments down
in the book and i look forward to
reading them but give us a preview
yes i do i address those in considerable
length
part of the you mentioned the
stubbornness aspect and he certainly
does get criticized for being stubborn
and
starts in 1955 where there's this
controversy between him versus these
armed religious sects
which some ways a little bit similar to
what we have in iraq right now but
the us government is telling him
you need to compromise with these sects
here
if you don't there's going to be civil
war
and ziem says
i don't think that's the way to go we
cannot allow there to be an independent
armed force within the country
and uh the americans keep telling him
and he keeps saying no
and uh
and he turns out to be right because he
puts down the sex
and that part of the reason why in the
future he won't listen to the americans
very much because they were clearly
wrong
on that
uh on that issue
another thing too with the sam and a lot
of the other vietnamese is they tend to
become more stubborn when the americans
try to tell them what to do
and
so
the ambassadors who are effective
particularly nolting or if you look at
someone like lansdale they attempt to
use persuasion rather than telling them
dictating to them
when cm is dictated to you he does he is
somewhat uh
stubborn as far as
his effectiveness as a leader
again this is where the communist
sources prove critical because
the
a lot of people have tried to say the
6263 period it's not really going that
well for zm but there's account after
account after count from the north
vietnamese side um and from the u.s side
and from the press who later on comes up
with this idea that things are going bad
to talk about how vigorous the
government is in
the strategic hamlet program building up
the militia forces
and just in general prosecuting
the war i mean mekong delta it's a
little more problematic but even there
it's it's uh
it's not in very bad shape so
that in nutshell would uh
summarize you know my answer to that
question
dr moyer i really enjoyed your book i i
had a question you mentioned uh and of
course anyone who's read the book knows
you the word iraq as you said is not
mentioned in your book
but uh you really weave a fascinating uh
story as you talk about the political
turmoil that exists in vietnam in the
time period you look at particularly the
misperceptions that the westerners have
about how politics and power works in
east asia um is there a corollary do you
believe uh with what's going on in iraq
today
uh yes certainly we've been in iraq
especially early on we were assuming
that we could apply our solutions our
western democratic forms of government
and that that was going to fly and
clearly that hasn't been the case um
we're learning
we're getting better on that but there's
still i think probably a ways to go
there
with respect to
the current situation with
the
iraqi prime minister who's now
fairly reluctant to accept our evidence
and we've been critical about how he's
dealing with the conflict there
i think there's a couple important
points there i mean one is that
the government in iraq right now does
not seem to be a nationalist government
which um i think is what is needed ziem
was effective because
he was a nationalist who did not try to
put the interests of one sect ahead of
another
the iraqi government now clearly seems
to be in favor of shia
forces
he's in in close contact with these
death squads and he's trying to to some
extent protect them against the uh
the us um and clearly i think you see
you've seen since the fall of hussein
some of the problems you have in vietnam
when you attempt liberalization i mean
it opens the door
for
subversion
leads to weak government
there's religious violence and so
i think americans are slowly realizing
that we can't
apply our model necessarily to there
as far as
iraqi
turning the iraqi government around we
put ourselves in a hole by uh through
the insistence on democracy because we
now it doesn't seem like we can easily
get
a nationalist leader in there who is
going to
try to to control the shia militia and
disarm them which is again you know
clearly when he disarmed the militias
that was a big boost to his power and
success and whether that's going to
happen now is
remains to be seen we have
somewhat similar situation in early 65
you've got the quad government which is
a
fairly weak government that's
subservient it to the militant buddhists
and
ultimately the military becomes so fed
up with him that
they get together in a big meeting where
they criticize when he finally agrees to
turn the country over to
essentially a military dictatorship
and
that will lead to return of stability
that military is a nationalist uh
predominantly nationalist and whether
there is a nationalist force like that
in iraq now is uh
is hard to say and through you know
debatification we got rid of a lot of
the the people who might have been able
to
to uh
accomplish that i mean we uh you know
clearly
a lot of people are revisiting this
issue of whether democracy was the best
way to go at least um
up front because
i mean a successful democracy doesn't
seem likely to come out of the
the chaos we're seeing there now and
you know ziem argued that
in a time of civil warfare you couldn't
have
um true democracy you had to first bring
stability and then maybe over the longer
term you could
could adopt a somewhat more uh liberal
form of government although he never
really wanted a true democracy but um
you know you see even in our civil war
lincoln certainly does some liberal
things and clamps down on
on opposition so
um
i think that's an issue we're gonna be
confronting seriously in the next few
months
we have time i think for one more
question we've
dr moyer you mentioned um
having access to the communist documents
you mentioned real briefly about china
being concerned about another korean war
did you find any evidence that china or
even the former soviet union were about
ready to withdraw their level of support
or involvement for vietnam
well there's a um
there's not talk of
withdrawing at this time but there there
is a lot of concern
um that they don't want to encourage the
vietnamese too much so the china does go
along with this invasion sort of very
reluctantly but they at the same time
are given the u.s signal i mean they
explicitly state in january 65 that
they're not going to you know fight the
us if the u.s doesn't attack them so
they i mean they can't afford to give up
completely now that particularly
interesting is the soviet union at this
time
uh
going through a transition in their
relations with north vietnam and up
until khrushchev's fall in 64 they've
been pretty standoffish but
new leadership comes in
they
for one thing the north vietnamese need
soviet assistance for anti-aircraft
weapons because the chinese don't have
it
but the the soviets also see this as a
way to get back at the chinese and uh
intrude into the chinese sphere because
by this time they're pretty they're on
pretty bitter terms with each other so
you see a ramp up in soviet support and
this creates a lot of this exacerbates
the tension between china and the soviet
union uh and also the tension between
north vietnam and it's two major patrons
um so
you know a lot of people thought the u.s
and going into vietnam would
bring the communists together but in
fact it it helps to divide them
well we are
out of time our
friends from c-span have
accommodated us for an hour so thanks
very much to them and uh we've got a
reception outside do you have any funnel
thank you very much for coming read the
book and tell your friends because it's
a very important contribution
mark moyer is an associate professor at
the u.s marine corps university in
quantico virginia for more information
about the book or the author mark moyer
visit triumphforsaken.com
[Music]